[Música]
Hola hoy en sciencelich las rotaciones
del espacio-tiempo
vivimos en un espacio geométrico en el
que podemos movernos rotar y medir
longitudes y ángulos
cada uno de nosotros tiene su propio
sistema de referencia nuestra propia
percepción del universo de la que somos
el centro y que nos permite identificar
los objetos que nos rodean en el sistema
de referencia de esta persona por
ejemplo el vehículo se mueve
pero en el sistema de referencia del
conductor es la persona la que se mueve
para describir el universo tres ejes son
suficientes
izquierda derecha arriba abajo delante
detrás
pero a principios del siglo XX esta
visión de un vuelco al comprender que el
tiempo es una cuarta dimensión del
universo hay un cuarto eje que debe
tenerse en cuenta la geometría de los
sistemas de referencia en este vídeo
intentaremos entender esta Revolución
que permite unificar no solo el espacio
y el tiempo sino también los campos
eléctrico y magnético o incluso el
movimiento y la energía
imaginemos una calle en la que una
persona a está de pie a un lado de la
calzada y la persona ve está al volante
de un automóvil
para describir su movimiento vamos a
construir un diagrama de espacio tiempo
para ello inmovilizamos cada momento y
apilamos las imágenes una sobre otras
estas forman un bloque que representa el
paso del tiempo en este bloque las dos
personas se desplazan hacia el futuro
trazando una línea del universo la
persona a traza una línea recta hacia el
futuro mientras que la persona ve sigue
una trayectoria inclinada
cada franja del diagrama marca la
posición de los objetos en un momento
dado
hasta ahora la situación se ha descrito
desde el punto de vista de la persona a
Pero cómo sería el diagrama si le
pidiéramos al conductor del automóvil
que lo volviese a dibujar desde su punto
de vista
en su sistema de referencia B está en el
centro del universo para formar su
diagrama tenemos que desplazar cada una
de las láminas Para volver a situarlo en
el centro de la escena
el automóvil está ahora en móvil y es la
persona a la que parece moverse hacia
atrás
hemos realizado una transformación de
Galileo trasladar sucesivamente las
rebanadas de espacio nos permite cambiar
nuestro sistema de referencia
a partir del siglo XVII los físicos
entendieron que el movimiento dependía
del observador para a era B quien se
movía pero para B era a quien se movía
ninguna de estas dos afirmaciones es más
cierta que la otra el movimiento es
relativo si B decide lanzar una pelota
la velocidad de la pelota le parecerá
mayor a a puesto que está siendo
impulsada por el automóvil
según Galileo las velocidades pueden
sumarse para cambiar el sistema de
referencia
esta idea puede parecer natural e
intuitiva pero los albores del siglo XX
un descubrimiento iba a ponerlo todo
entre dicho
imaginemos que cada una de las dos
personas Enciende una linterna
[Música]
si no tenemos en cuenta la presencia del
aire que la ralentiza la luz sale de las
dos lámparas a 299 millones
792.458 metros por segundo visto desde
la carretera cabría esperar que el has
lanzado por B viajará más rápido sumando
las velocidades
Pero los dos Rayos de Luz tienen
exactamente la misma velocidad
esta velocidad tan precisa es absoluta
cualquiera que sea el objeto que se
desplace a 299 millones
792.458 metros por segundo tendrá
siempre la misma velocidad en todos los
sistemas de referencia se le bautizó
como velocidad de la luz
la conmoción fue drástica cómo es
posible que esta velocidad no se sume a
la del automóvil por qué A diferencia de
la pelota la luz no cambia de velocidad
de un punto de vista a otro
para comprender la magnitud del problema
imaginemos que a emite dos Rayos de Luz
a cada lado en su sistema de referencia
los dos ases tienen la misma velocidad
pero en el sistema de referencia de B el
diagrama se distorsiona con respecto al
anterior la luz debería viajar más
rápido en una dirección que en la otra
sin embargo no cambia
la solución la encontraron varios
investigadores a principios del siglo XX
para que la velocidad de la luz
permaneciera en variante con Las
observaciones había que distorsionar el
diagrama desplazando no solo las
rebanadas de espacio sino también las de
tiempo
a los investigadores no les queda más
remedio ya que es la única forma de
cambiar los marcos de referencia sin
alterar la velocidad de la luz y sin
distorsionar las rectas ni los volúmenes
del diagrama
se llama transformación de Lorenz
La idea es asombrosa en contra de la
intuición el tiempo y el espacio se
distorsionan en función del observador
las duraciones entre acontecimientos el
orden en que se producen e incluso la
longitud de los objetos se convierten en
medidas relativas que cambian de un
punto de vista a otro
estos dos acontecimientos ocurren con un
segundo de diferencia en este sistema de
referencia pero con un segundo y una
décima de diferencia en el otro sistema
de referencia el automóvil mide 4 metros
en su sistema de referencia pero es
ligeramente más corto en el sistema de
referencia de la carretera cuando un
cuerpo se mueve nuestro sistema de
referencia su reloj parece funcionar a
cámara lenta y su longitud parece
contraerse se trata de la relatividad
especial
hagamos un breve paréntesis si se mira
desde arriba una ciudad puede escribirse
en un mapa que muestra las calles y su
trazado
si giramos el mapa la posición y la
dirección de las calles parece cambiar
pero esto es solo una ilusión la
orientación del mapa es arbitraria una
descripción abstracta del mundo que no
tiene ningún impacto en la realidad
los físicos No tardaron en establecer
una analogía entre el diagrama de
espacio-tiempo y un mapa el diagrama de
espacio-tiempo no es más que una
descripción abstracta del universo y al
igual que un mapa se puede cambiar el
punto de vista para mirarlo
En otras palabras las transformaciones
de Lawrence que nos permiten cambiar
nuestro sistema de referencia
equivaldrían a las rotaciones de nuestro
mapa
esta idea tiene sentido porque al igual
que las rotaciones las transformaciones
de Lawrence preservan las rectas y los
volúmenes
pero a diferencia de las rotaciones
clásicas las transformaciones de
Lawrence parecen distorsionar el
diagrama no conservan las distancias
entre puntos algunos se alejan otros se
acercan
y mientras que las rotaciones dibujan
círculos estas dibujan hipérbolas
[Música]
Cómo podrían tales transformaciones ser
análogas a las rotaciones
banca Gaming cosqui tuvi tuvieron una
idea brillante intentaron una nueva
forma de medir las distancias en el
diagrama la métrica de
[Música]
según ellos nuestro diagrama es
abstracto y no representa fielmente las
distancias reales un poco como un
planisferio que distorsiona la
superficie de la Tierra para hacer la
plana
aunque no lo parezca todos los puntos
que componen una hipérbola estarían en
realidad a la misma distancia del centro
la hipérbola sería el análogo del
círculo la curva cuyos puntos están
todos a la misma distancia del centro
al cambiar el sistema de referencia los
puntos se deslizan a lo largo de las
hipérbolas y todos permanecen a la misma
distancia del centro con la métrica de
milkovsky la analogía se vuelve perfecta
y las transformaciones de lorents son
efectivamente el análogo de las
rotaciones son rotaciones hiperbólicas
A diferencia de una rotación clásica
una rotación hiperbólica distingue dos
tipos de dirección las duraciones que
pueden trazarse en el eje del tiempo
y las longitudes que pueden trazarse en
el eje del espacio las duraciones y las
longitudes son intervalos de naturaleza
diferentes intervalos de tiempo o de
espacio y Los Rayos de Luz forman un
cono Que los separa fundamentalmente
una duración sigue siendo una duración y
una longitud sigue siendo una longitud
así puesto que cada observador se mueve
hacia su propio futuro es imposible
retroceder en el tiempo estamos
confinados dentro de estos conos de luz
y en todos los sistemas de referencia el
futuro sigue siendo el futuro
una rotación clásica acaba siempre en el
mismo punto tras girar 360 grados pero
una rotación hiperbólica puede girar
indefinidamente Pues el ángulo de
rotación ya no se mide sobre un círculo
sino sobre una hipérbola que se extiende
hasta el infinito se puede rotar en el
espacio tiempo tanto como se quiera
el ángulo de una rotación del
espacio-tiempo se denomina rapidez mide
lo rápido que es un sistema de
referencia con respecto a otro la
rapidez de un automóvil en relación con
la carretera es el ángulo entre su
sistema de referencia y el de la
carretera si el automóvil acelera su
rapidez aumenta y se acelera durante un
tiempo infinitamente largo acabará
alcanzando la velocidad de la luz
la velocidad de la luz corresponde en
realidad a una rapidez infinita es la
velocidad máxima que un objeto podría
alcanzar solo acelerando durante un
tiempo infinitamente largo la luz es
infinitamente rápida
cuando ve lanza una pelota no es su
velocidad la que se añade la el vehículo
sino su rapidez
y así cuando ve emite luz
como su rapidez es infinita
sigue siendo la misma cuando se le añade
la rapidez del automóvil
los físicos van descubriendo poco a poco
la geometría del espacio-tiempo mucho
más que un diagrama abstracto el
espacio-tiempo es ahora una entidad
física por sí misma con distancias y
rotaciones esta Nueva Visión ha
permitido a los científicos comprender
que el espacio y el tiempo no son más
que dimensiones de un único objeto el
espacio-tiempo permite comprender mejor
la noción de aceleración
se dice que un objeto acelera cuando su
movimiento cambia ya sea de velocidad o
de dirección
pero en el espacio-tiempo entendemos que
ambos casos son rotaciones una rotación
clásica o una rotación hiperbólica
acelerar es de hecho lo mismo que rotar
en el espacio-tiempo
el espacio-tiempo también permite
unificar los campos eléctricos y
magnéticos un campo eléctrico genera una
fuerza que acelera las partículas
cargadas mientras con campo magnético
genera una fuerza que las hace girar
estas dos situaciones son análogas al
igual que campo magnético el campo
eléctrico hace girar las partículas pero
con rotaciones hiperbólicas en el
espacio-tiempo el campo eléctrico es la
versión temporal del campo magnético
por último esta visión unifica las
nociones de impulso y energía en efecto
la energía es el análogo temporal del
impulso Mientras que el primero mide el
movimiento en el espacio el segundo mide
el movimiento en el tiempo un objeto
inmóvil por ejemplo no tiene impulso no
se mueve en el espacio pero tiene
energía porque se mueve en el tiempo
hacia el futuro
Y si el objeto acelera su velocidad
cambia gira en el espacio-tiempo y gana
impulso y energía
a medida que se acerca a la velocidad de
la luz estas dos cantidades tienden al
infinito
las transformaciones de Lawrence no son
más que rotaciones abstractas de nuestro
mapa del universo cambios de punto de
vista que no afectan a la verdadera
geometría del espacio-tiempo pero en los
años siguientes Einstein y sus
contemporáneos descubrieron que el
universo podía deformarse y curvarse en
las proximidades de las estrellas
masivas Lo que explicaba el fenómeno de
la gravedad era la relatividad general
la teoría de la relatividad especial no
se abandonó por ello al igual que la
tierra que es Curva pero parece plana a
pequeña escala el espacio-tiempo es
curvo pero está muy bien descrito
localmente por la métrica de mikovsky
esta es la base de nuestra comprensión
del universo hoy en día nuevas teorías
intentan comprender esta geometría a
escala de las partículas es el espacio
tiempo perfectamente liso o está cortado
en pequeños fragmentos tiene más
dimensiones que estarían enroscadas y
por tanto serían invisibles a nuestra
escala o fluctúa sometido al dictado de
las fluctuaciones cuánticas las ideas
abundan con la esperanza de alcanzar
algún día una comprensión fundamental
del universo
[Música]